[Music]
where am
I what is
this I
feel
wow this feels
[Music]
good
wo
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
woo this is something
else
Flint
Marco what do you want from me remember
Ben
Parker the old man you shot down in Cold
Blood what does it matter to you
anyway
everything
[Music]
it's time to pay Marco
a
[Music]
go
[Applause]
[Music]
good
riddance would you like a
drink I'm sorry what was I thinking bad
for the Public Image right Mr key to the
city what did you do to her
I did what you failed to do I was there
for her Mary Jane and I we understand
each other she doesn't know what you are
Peter she knows me very well and when
she kissed me it was just like she used
to kiss
me that
taste
[Music]
strawberries
how do you like that
Spidey that all you
got stinks doesn't it I protected you in
high school now I'm going to kick your
little
[Music]
ass
you going to kill me like you killed my
father I'm done trying to convince you
you took him from me he loved me no he
despised you you were an embarrassment
to
him
oh look at little golin
Jr going to
cry
[Music]
shillo Mr Parker Dr Connor's here oh Dr
Connor's how are you quite a specimen
you left me
Parker it's chemistry is not unlike a
kritic meteorites of the
70s that's good you know what par
par Parker come
smoke it amplifies characteristics of
its host hey give me out a cook
especially
aggression this could be dangerous Peter
you didn't keep any did you you got any
with nuts um I have some nuts I could
make some go make me some Peter no no no
of course
not
your shots are so good I'd love to shoot
you
sometime Peter
Parker Peter Parker this bran that's not
the position I hired you for black suit
Spider-Man Peter these are
incredible you got to have these Jonah
I'll pay you the usual
rate if you want the shots I'll take the
staff job double
[Music]
[Applause]
money so
Everybody Somebody That Soul everybody
[Music]
somebody get
up
[Music]
ah
Parker
[Music]
sh